kamel anti board chinois
jamais
un jour mon casse toi pov con chavez
tout est prêt pour lentilles portrait
chinois
alors je dis n'est pas tout à fait fini
rien je trouve que
c'est une bonne chose dans ton
job ça fera une heure y'a pas de
couilles reviendra plus et ça une heure
je suis désolé je voulais pas le faire
au départ comme
papa je le fais dissidente et portrait
chinois d'accord
montre du red star mais là quand même
pour le croyait pas les piqueteurs ce
qui faisait hier si il disait des
blagues racistes
ça fait trois jours qu'il cherche
juliette ahmadi [ __ ] c'est dégueulasse
j'avais lutté près savoir heureusement
je sais qu'ici mais t'inquiète de
la vie djamel un but est venu avec une
armée de [ __ ]
depuis que lorsqu'il fait il fait début
des petites semaines du match grave
c'est juste muriel que je voulais pas 10
et j'en ai pris un peu mais c'est très
triste
formation ma proposition loyale et on
peut tout faire maintenant tout bouge
pas une oreille
bravo je peux maintenant je mets ce que
tu sais qu'il faut sur droite c'est fait
exprès ou pas oublier les tickets de
ces tickets ça s'appelle le style
ça s'appelle du vol
jamais tu sais que des parents de muriel
il vend des chaussures donc aller au
cours
monde est prêt ouais si c'était un gros
mot attends je vais juste vérifier un
truc
jamais on n'y arrivera jamais à
l'arrivée du millième à l'étude
saint-quentin papoose bénard à ces mecs
de banlieue c'était
sa mort et chercheurs bon
les
sénateurs et lesbiens j'étais trop petit
c'est très bien vas-y tu t'étais un gros
mot sa mère lipopette
c'était une guerre une guerre si j'étais
une guerre voilà que
je serai avec la guerre contre les
pointes sèches et des cheveux cassants
c'était un accident la coupe du monde
non la dernière coupe du monde a donné
un coup dur c'était un dictateur
si j'étais un dictateur de charlie
chaplin j'étais à bout et
j'étais un gorille le bruit qui court
que je suis pas régulier de billups a
un truc je sais pas moi c'est après
l'émission de m6 des ter alsace à
zinedine zidane
sans exception tu es d une trahison mon
bras droit ces [ __ ] ils n'écoutent
pas confiant cela
c'était un meuble
un canapé convertible pour le convertir
à l'islam
qu'ils étaient un supplice
voté chirac en 2002 ça c'est un supplice
c'était un légume chirac ne
fait pas mieux
si l'état fait peur
j'étais un terroriste carlos
papayou papayou l'aîné
c'était un saint
maclou pour les moquettes
saint michel pour l'heure
il été un supplice je recommence le
record
j'ai été un supplice reste gros coup là
ça m'inquiète de remettre
ces nouveaux tout en haut
c'est incroyable dit il j'ai pas envie
de te taper devant tout le monde tu fais
des
c'est quoi ton tu rigoles comme un conte
de cette blague c'est pour ça qu'il y va
aussi après des regards il surenchérit
arrête
mais en plus il dit white spirit
c'est bien le regard change pas du feu
non mais sans blague pas qu'est ce que
c'est ça tu peux je te tiens mais je ne
peux pas rester comme ça c'est pas
possible que quelqu'un qui les cailles
trop d'entre eux sont en plateau plus ça
y est j'ai attrapé la crève un petit
manteau pour jamel
pas une petite culotte courte durée
petite écharpe
vas-y vas-y pardon si tu étais un animal
mon frère mob
des impôts
tant
d'ardeur tout le monde a peur
je n'arrive pas intervenue non tu sais
pourquoi parce que gillett avait pas
beaucoup dormi c'est ça aussi c'était un
impôt mon père et si c'était une ordure
le père noël ouais tu m'as il m'a oublié
moyens dernière rien ramené j'ai
commandé à la strate cpc 464
janadi et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de linda hardy tube abonnez vous mettez
un peu de bleu